[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui on a donc une info exclusive du
magazine publie nga vous révéler dans le
numéro qui sortira demande apprend qu
ophélie winter serait devenu sdf et
serait ruiné obligé 10 dans l'article de
dormir dans sa voiture
ça paraît incroyable quand on voit la
carrière qu'elle a fait vous avez un
petit récapitulatif qui résume la
carrière d'ophélie winter immense star
regarde la carrière de fait les winter
commence au début des années 90 en 1994
elle se fait repérer par m6 et anime
dance machine 4 puis le hit machine qui
la fera connaître des ados lien avec
l'arrêt récemment qu'ils en avaient
marre de l'image de businessman pour
l'école plus que le bal quoi c'est
l'année suivante que son tube dieu m'a
donné la foi fait de la jeune femme une
véritable star présente sur toutes les
radios et les chaînes de clips
[Musique]
delas en chaîne les tubes et les clips à
succès faisons d'ophélie winter une
chanteuse incontournable des
collaborations avec des artistes
internationaux comme culio lui
apporteront une légitimité jusqu'à la
sortie de son troisième album en 2003
qui s'écoulera à plus de 80 mille
exemplaires et dont le single sache sera
disque d'argent
[Musique]
un titre dont le clip sera réalisé par
luc besson avec la participation de
gérard depardieu
rien que ça en dehors de la musique
ophélie winter apparaît dans plusieurs
films et séries en 2009 elle tente un
come back avec l'album résurrection qui
ne rencontrera malheureusement pas son
public quatre ans plus tard c'est l'une
de ses dernières apparitions dans les
médias elle participe à la cinquième
saison de danse avec les stars
aujourd'hui d'après public ophélie
winter serait devenu sdf
alors selon vous la célébrité est elle
dangereuse voilà donc sachiez on va tout
vous dire on a eu ophélie winter au
téléphone on aura des infos dans un
instant elle a vécu des choses très
difficiles
elle n'aura d'ailleurs nous en parler
lundi dans tpm pays hôte
ophélie donc avant d'être connue pour
ses tubes ophélie winter a commencé à la
télé elle a présenté le hit machine sur
m6 c'était l'étoile montant à 1994 et 95
équipes noël exactement il y avait deux
jumeaux noël yvon hervé exactement
d'ophélie winter stenwick machine pas lé
pa de 20 ans par exemple il vaut mieux
être devant la télé pour voir johnny
hallyday que oui dans sa série policière
david lansky qui est diffusé à 20 45 sur
la chèvre en attendant demain soir en
off screen qui rentre dans le type
machine thématiques avec l'album smash
pour la gueule un deuxième place
galloway avait dit alors elle a été
aussi juré de popstars bien sûr nouvelle
fait plein de choses on va revenir
dessus
ophélie son immense carrière je pense qu
elle nous regarde actuellement beaucoup
elle sera avec nous lundi est là elle a
eu un autre grand moment dans sa
carrière ats qu'elle a présenté la
première cérémonie ça j'avais oublié les
nerfs genève arrive sur tf1 en direct de
l ain ce trophée lit et c'est une
animatrice exceptionnel sienne manga
devrait elle est très très fort
[Applaudissements]
hommage
c'est un jeu
[Musique]
alors bernard au foehn winter donc
demain dans le magazine public
il sortirait cette info exclusive comme
quoi serait devenu sdf et serait ruiné
obligés de dormir dans sa voiture
est-ce que vous avez des infos nous
l'avons eu aux fidji également oui alors
j'espère que c'est pas possible tout ce
qu'il raconte parce que bon public est
un magazine très sérieux évidemment et
l'admettre en couverture et où ils ont
l'air très sûr de leurs infos en fait
quand elle était à dubaï avec eux bon
avec un fiancé disons le un elle est
rentrée de dubaï précipitamment je crois
que c'est ils sont tendus s'engueuler et
c est resté dans un petit hôtel à paris
pendant plusieurs jours et n'a pas pu
payer le reste de l'hôtel donc elle dort
dans sa voiture une petite smart en plus
elle dort dans le huitième quand même
mais qui est un des quartiers chics de
paris
et voilà la voiture est rempli de choses
et d'autres et c'est très triste parce
qu'autant de cette fille qui est une
fille formidable qui est intelligente
qui qui sait faire beaucoup de choses
qui est belle je suis sidéré qu'elle en
arrive là
la pauvre c'est vraiment ça me fait
beaucoup de peine alors à la formidable
d'énormes tubes aussi à ophélie marie
louise est une star des années 90 quand
je vous dis notamment avec dieu m'a
donné la foi
[Musique]
noir
j'aime
bah
la fois
je n'en sais quoi
[Musique]
j'en ai connu des ventes ont fortement
ce qu'il a pu faire
[Musique]
alors donc la fin 87 ou mouvement a
parlé aujourd'hui quand ça a commencé à
sortir parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
talent immense
donc d'où la question descente aux
enfers des stars la célébrité est elle
dangereuse on parlera mallaury nataf une
des stars aussi du des séries ab
productions c'est vrai qu ophélie winter
un talent immense
aujourd'hui oui juste ajouter quelque
chose d'important parce que vous savez
qu'un au niveau psychologique
bon c'est sûr qu'à la fin ça pas trop
marché morales avait influencé les
parties avec cette histoire d'amour
c'est très bien elle a eu raison
en revanche les réels accidents de
voiture très grave aussi qui l'a
immobilisé pendant trois mois à
l'hôpital
alors ça je sais pas ce qu'elle avait
communiqué sur instagram à l'époque et
ça a été très dur après pour se remettre
dans le coup alors elle a trouvé un
coach je me rappelle à dubaï ça s'est
très très bien passé
et puis là il rentre en france
évidemment vous savez les gens réalisent
pas que même quand on te voit plus à la
télé que tu saches chanteurs ou acteurs
ou autres tu gagnes pas d'argent
l'argent il rentre pas si on te voit pas
l'argent ne rentre pas donc forcément je
crois qu'effectivement à doha des
problèmes de sous et c'est bien
regrettable d'autant plus que je sais
qu'elle voit plus sa maman non plus
depuis quelques mois donc étonnant c'est
qu'elle ait pas des amis qu'elle peut
appeler elle a des amis qui l'héberge
voilà ghz et parfois hébergés chez des
potes voilà c'est normal mais c'est vrai
que mine de rien il ya plein de gens qui
m'ont dit mais c'est pas possible donc
bernard comment comment on arrive comme
ça à valve ait c'était une star des
années 90 comment décès violent la
célébrité c'est quelque chose de violent
surtout beau encore plus pour une femme
je pense parce que c'est lié à la beauté
à la séduction bon madame c'est pareil
même elle est elle est très belle et
toujours certainement très belle même si
les photos de demain dans public en
couverture sont assez dures mais elle
est c'est très dur quand vous êtes au
sommet que d'un coup plus personne nous
appelle on vous fait plus confiance le
téléphone ne sonne pas donc vous fait
rien et vous êtes bloqués parce que tous
les gens croisés dans la rue ils vous
disent ah non mais alors alentours a pu
à la télé que tu fais que sous fait vous
chantez plus fait plus rien et ça
devient un truc qui devient dans la tête
c'est comme une obsession au train de
vie on a l'habitude d'un train de vie
c'est énorme c'est bon et conséquent
sable ça baisse un peu mais c'est plus
compliqué et benjamins je vais on va
parler de fermeture mais je voulais
m'arrêter des ondes sur vous c'est vrai
que voilà on sait vous aussi vous avez
eu des voulaient que leurs pleurs non
pas du tout racontez nous comment
comment parce que moi il ya plein
je te le dis bonjour voilà que j'ai dit
aux téléspectateurs ce soir c'est qu'il
ya plein de gens aujourd'hui benjamin
mine de rien voilà ne croyez pas qu'ils
roulent sur l'or et que benjamin il faut
vraiment qu'ils viennent tous les jours
qui travaille à fond il se donne à fond
pour travailler je peux vous dire qu'il
est hyper sérieux parce qu'il n'a pas
envie de perdre son job
ils me disent mais attends benjamin
castaldi il a amassé des mini d'euros
comment aujourd'hui il peut se dire on
peut se dire qu'il est [ __ ] des
difficultés parfois moi j'ai enfin
franchement quand on est dans le ça se
passe ni contre franchement quand tu es
dans un dans un comme ça dans un mot
vous tout va bien les banquiers vous
font confiance ils vous ouvrent des
comptes en banque qui voulait ça les
attendait dans des découverts abyssal ça
descend ça descend mais tout va bien les
scop ou brasser beaucoup de pognon
bon ça y'a pas de quoi les pays peut se
passer dans la levée dans la carrière
vous perdez un contrat mois de vie bon
j'ai perdu mon exclu sur tf1 tout en
restant sur la chaîne donc
et là on perd beaucoup d'argent d'un
coup et puis un jour blanc qui vous
appelle le découvert il faut le il faut
le fait il faut le remplacer
moi j'ai eu en plus pas eu de bol c'est
que j'ai été j'ai mis un peu d'argent
dans différentes affaires qui étaient
pas très pas très peur et santé qui
permettent d escroquerie et c'est vrai
que moi j'ai connu arp a connu une
descente mais ça a été très très chaud
c'est à dire que j'ai connu le moment où
vous allez allez allez à la carte bleue
et vous pu tirer va mal ça n'a pas duré
très longtemps
j'avais encore ma maison mais la maison
après on vous l'apprends aux propos
magnol la maison tout et c'est vrai que
je parraine des enfants dont ils ont osé
mais n'en vois pas faire dans la voiture
et en disant au revoir à la maison parce
que la maison on avait perdu donc perdu
votre maison bien sûr ça peut arriver ça
peut arriver comme moi je suis
responsable d'une certaine façon parce
que j'ai très bien vécu qui était très
généreux over je suis pas d'accord avec
ça moi j'étais j'ai été très généreux
j'ai toujours pensé que tu as fait pour
être dépensés et pour en profiter
donc quand ça allait bien et j'ai été
très généreux et puis c'est vrai que
j'ai pas été très prévoyants j'aurais pu
me dire j'ai écouté ce que je n'ai pas
fait il faut faire d'ailleurs mais c'est
vrai que à tous les niveaux et croyez
pas que ce soit une question de niveau
d'argent il ya des gens qui ont des
millions d'euros des millions d'euros
qui date d'un jour à l'autre peut avoir
plus rien c'est possible c'est possible
pour alors voilà comment c'est possible
à gérer salle mais non merci un contrat
incroyable ça mais le juge demande vous
perdez de contrat une fois vous perdez
donc une forte somme tous les mois vous
avez des impôts tous les mois et puis et
puis quand une banque vous dis monsieur
castaldi
je les ai vécus vous dis c'est terminé
croyez moi c'est terminé c'est à dire
quoi ces termes vous à peine atteint
même ses cascades et maintenant c'est
fini donc le découvert il y en a plus
il faut le rembourser et puis vous avez
des impôts et en deux en deux trois mois
vous êtes vous êtes tout bascule et je
vous jure que c'est vrai c'est pas faire
pleurer parce que ces propos mais que
vous ayez peu d'argent moyennement
d'argent pour beaucoup d'argent ça peut
arriver ça peut arriver
voilà c'est il faut le savoir et c'est
pas faut arrêter de dire que c'est
devait cesser d'aider des stars sont
toutes inconsciente et font n'importe
quoi il y en a qui font n'importe quoi
mais j'ai fait un peu n'importe quoi
mais il était victime d'une énorme
escroquerie qui m'a fait perdre
l'intégralité de ce que j'avais mis de
côté c'était aujourd'hui vous n'avez
rien de côté belge ml j'ai pas de député
ivan maison j'ai lu mon appartement j'ai
pu bagnole on vit très bien
c'est quand même très heureux c'est vrai
qu'on n'avait pas d'argent tu te connais
pas du tout annonce tout ce que vous
avez amassé lors de votre carrière là
plus rien plus rien c'est zéro j'en sais
quoi mais c'est vrai que si dense
puisque benjamin il en parle tout à fait
trouver une main et c'est vrai que c'est
maintenant le moins touché que je moi
j'étais très bon jeu m'a jamais à un
moment il y avait beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent je me suis encore mais les
montants lui appartiennent de sa feuille
d'impôts et des montants qu'ils avaient
en mensualités tout ça c'est vrai que
c'était pas un gros flambeur cqcam très
très généreux et le problème c'est que
quand je vais rentrer n'arrive plus à
elle des sorties elle continue à dire
que vous avez encore deux trois voitures
qui sont les hymne gay qui partent tous
les mois il ya encore l'emprunt qui
partent tous les mois ça veut dire que
les mensualités d'impôt sur l'année
précédente par tous les mois il y aura
un ou deux ans vous creusez un découvert
et tim wilson
moi je vais me faire l'avocat du diable
et des lions si je regarde et il ya des
gens qui se disent moi je gagnerai pas
ce que gagnent benjamin castaldi en tête
ans dont deux ont assuré
bien sûr ton toute une vie mais je suis
d'accord tienne vous avez raison mais le
problème c'est pas une question de
volume d'argent c'est une question de
situation que vous que vous ayez un
petit salaire 1 ou un gros salaire quand
ça quand on gagne une couille dans le
potage qui ont hâte de les croiser au
moyen d'outils quand ça existe un
système grip
les gens qui vous ont fait confiance le
banquier qui vous a autorisé un petit
découvert il vous dit stop vous pouvez
plus rien faire et ça c'est une
situation moi j'ai eu la chance d'être
aidés parce que j'ai la chance d'avoir
une famille qui a pu m'aider etc mais je
vous jure que cantat banque et ou quand
la situation se grippe
c'est terminé mais moi j'ai je tenais le
frigo d'une main et dates et les mots
parce que les huissiers viennent chez
vous et ils veulent tout vous prendre
c'est normal vous avez des dettes il
faut bien les payer mais moi je veux pas
faire de procès de ces gens là qui ont
des problèmes parce que parce qu'elle va
en parler c'est vraiment une question de
voilà quand il se pourrait qu'il faut
être prévoyant équipe moi mes grands
parents étaient très prévoyant par
exemple il est gonflé de l'argent il
mettait de côté
moi j'ai pas d'une génération qui met de
côté voilà ses formes pour en revenir
l'autre info du jour ce qu'on partait
d'ophélie winter ce qui selon la une de
public sourit donc ils disent sdf donc
sans domicile fixe est terrible voilà
ophélie je sais qu'il y en a qui veulent
réagir là-dessus
géraldine ophélie on se racontait
beaucoup à une époque on était dans la
même agence de mannequins et on sortait
beaucoup elle n'était pas encore connu
moi j'ai vu le basculement dans la
grande notoriété et e
j'adore ophélie c'est possible mais
c'est une grande écorchée vive aussi et
effectivement ce basculement dans la
lumière moi je pense que j'ai toujours
pensé que la célébrité c'était bien mais
en fait ça bursa boursouflé go ça
d'illac le narcissisme mais après qu'est
ce qu'on en fait en fait de cette
notoriété
comment elle s'est entourée est ce
qu'elle est très bien entouré ce qu'elle
a dû elle se choisir aussi les bons
projets à ce qu'elle a su dire non et ça
c'est enfin je pense que c'est aussi ce
qui ce qu'il faut lui dire mais voilà ça
me fait beaucoup de peine parce que
c'est quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup et
qui est très sensible et elle doit être
très seul parce que si elle a plus sa
maman elle a un frère je crois qu'elle
le voit plus aussi avec son papa depuis
le début elle avait été complètement
abandonné gens qu'elle doit être très
très seul jean luc azoulay vous est pour
moi le plus grand producteur de télé je
le dis et pas seulement voilà si ma
jolie de l'histoire la télé cécile et je
le dis vraiment ah oui sans flagornerie
pour moi vous êtes le numéro un de très
loin non plus comment on peut arriver à
être une telle star comme ophélie winter
on va parler de mallaury nataf juste
après qu'elle eut non moins grande
carrière que cofely et se retrouver
comme ça à la une d'un magazine people
en étant sdf est-ce que vous avez vu
vous aussi vous avez vu d'autres cas
comme ça est ce que ça vous étonne de
laponie j'ai connu quatre ou cinq ans
parce que je faisais le tour n'est de
rmc et sa mère était une des chamois z
c'est à dire qu'elle venait du chamois
d'or d'accord et toute la troupe et
politiques une petite fille qui était là
avec la fille de jean pierre foucault et
gelé virginie que j'embrassais déjà
donné absolument oui qui avait offert un
tombeau pour son anniversaire si mal et
les foudres de gens de jean-pierre
d'accord société la gelée connu je les
ai suivis c'est une fille adorable haye
est là je l ai là peut-être tourné pour
nous ça y est tournée pour nous quand
elle a commencé et c'est une fille
adorable
le problème c'est que la célébrité est
toujours quelque chose de fragile et le
succès c'est toujours une chose de
fragile si on ne retient pas si on n'est
pas très sérieux si on ne fait pas
attention on se retrouve très vite pris
au piège et c'est des gens qui gagnent
très jeune beaucoup d'argent
relativement qui ne savent pas que la
vie est dure qui ne s'attaquait des
impôts qui a les banquiers qui a tout ce
que dont tu parlais benjamin et qui se
retrouvent quand ça marche moins bien
pour soi n'y a plus rien et c'est le
trou voilà c'est tout il c'est
l'inconscience du fait qu' il pense que
le succès est normal il pense que ça va
continuer toute leur vie parce qu'ils
sont des êtres élus or personne et notre
élu le succès ça se fabrique du travail
c'est de la chance et si un jour on
arrête et on a plus de succès on n'a
plus d'argent